it really is the end of an era in the
reality show world keeping up with the
kardashians made the family
rich and famous beyond their wildest
dreams and it also transformed the
e-network
so why in the world would you pull the
plug we spoke to executive producer ryan
seacrest today
this was a very very hard decision for
them to make they were emotional we were
trading texts and emails after the
announcement
ryan's words come hours after kim's
bombshell instagram post
telling fans quote 14 years 20 seasons
this show made us who we are i am so
incredibly grateful
we asked the busy sisters about
potentially slowing down last year
you mentioned that you might be ready to
say goodbye to keeping up with the
kardashians
where are you at on that um like are you
tired i don't want to do anything
focused on like beauty fragrance
skims law school mom
not necessarily in that order but that
is more than enough for me
a source tells e.t they're ending things
next year because the show takes up a
lot of time
quote the kids who started the show now
have their own kids and it's getting
very hard to film all together or get
enough footage separately
even if my wife were to divorce me of
course the shocker comes just seven
weeks after kanye's campaign rally
breakdown
and twitter rampage at his wife and her
family i've seen him go through
a lot so what does this mean for e the
network has lost quite a few major
programs this year i don't have to worry
about that anymore barry cavallari is
gone after kristen filed for divorce
five weeks ago they canceled three shows
including e news
after 29 years on the air so is e's
future in jeopardy
when you think of e you think of keeping
up with the kardashians
you know look there are a lot of shows
that e has like total bellas they've
brought back
the soup but many of us are wondering
what is their future lineup
really going to look like kim you're
doing amazing you'll stay out of those
magazines i'll try never never
e.t has been keeping up since before
their first episode even
aired the show spawned 12 spin-offs and
covered everything
from kim and her sisters marriages
divorces children
two cheating an overdose a robbery and
caitlyn's transition
but the ratings have tanked christianity
from 10.5 million viewers in 2011 to
just over 850
000 this year with angry fans lighting
up twitter over this
courtney kim throwdown one calling it
cringeworthy and trash
those ratings no longer warrant the cost
of their crazy salary
reportedly 30 million per season the
family has raked in about 250 million in
10 years
and then there's the instagram factor
when you go to social media you learn so
much so in a way
when you tune in to a new season of the
kardashians it kind of feels like old
news
you